foreign
[Music]
this is a video about life in other
dimensions
flat life forms and 2D Landscapes
psychedelic entities with higher spatial
geometry even beings that can ignore
time while our 3D brains can typically
only perceive a limited number of
Dimensions with the help of computer
simulations in a bit of sci-fi
creativity we can conceptualize some
truly mind-blowing hypothetical
realities so say goodbye to the 3D World
you know and prepare for life in lower
and higher dimensions
[Music]
a man
we'll start by voyaging down a
dimensional layer to a universe of 2D
life
the beings of this universe can only
move onto axes with no conception of
depth
if we were to stick our faces through
the flat plane of their world the visual
might be frightening as the
two-dimensional life forms would only be
able to perceive infinitely thin slices
of her three-dimensional bodies at a
time a bit like the images on an MRI
machine to those beings we would be
shapeshifters whose bodies appear from
nowhere and disappear with no
explanation but could life really
function in 2D sure here's some now this
is a simulation running in Alien an
artificial Life program that lets you
build two-dimensional ecosystems these
virtual cells might not be life as we
typically Define it but they do
self-replicate and adapt to
environmental changes there's a lot of
impressive 2D life simulators out there
but for 2D life to exist outside of a
computer it couldn't be made of the same
3D atoms we're familiar with scientist
Tim hurton successfully simulated a
molecule in just two Dimensions so our
hypothetical 2D organism could be made
of these bead like opponents one of the
biggest hurdles for two-dimensional life
would likely be its innards nearly all
three-dimensional animals are built
around a digestive tract that passes
through their bodies with a hole on one
end for eating and a hole on the other
end for uh expelling but if a
two-dimensional life form had such a
system it would cut the organism in half
as this Advanced simulation shows with
the bifurcated segments of the life form
falling apart but there might be a
solution certain animals like sea
anemones have just one hole for all
their various whole related needs which
is something I'm not going to think too
hard about but perhaps their theoretical
2D life form could have a similar system
with a single aperture leading to a
simple digestive tract of course it's
worth noting that just because something
could exist it doesn't mean it does as
far as we're aware there is no secret
realm of 2D life it's just an
interesting hypothetical
but what would happen if we went up a
level to a universe of 4D life the
Innovative game 4D toys is a way for us
three-dimensional life forms to start
getting our minds around
four-dimensional objects at first these
objects don't seem to make sense
changing shape as we move them and even
disappearing from view entirely what's
happening to answer that let's return to
our metaphor of a 2d being observing 3D
objects passing through its flat realm
from our perspective these 3D objects
are straightforward but to the 2D life
form they don't follow familiar rules
appearing and disappearing for seemingly
no reason as 3D beings we can see the
objects just fell into the third
dimension outside of the 2D plane but
the 2D entity has no awareness of this
and that's exactly what's happening to
us in 4D toys we are three-dimensional
beings that can only see a limited 3D
slice of larger fourth dimensional
objects take this ball pit filled with
240 hyperspheres at first it doesn't
seem like there's that many spheres on
screen but if we move our third
dimensional slice through the fourth
dimension just like you can move a
two-dimensional slice through the third
dimension we see the Spheres are all
there after all this model of the fourth
dimension is more than something the
developer made up these shapes have long
been researched in geometry and objects
like tesseracts essentially 4D cubes are
well-documented structures now some of
you might be thinking wait the fourth
dimension is time hold on to that
comment we're going to get to it for now
there's lots of cool stuff you can make
in 4D like this 600-sided die or fourth
dimensional abacuses which really make
me feel like a baby fumbling around with
a toy ever tried to fit a tesseract into
a 4D hole it's not easy I'm convinced
this is how USBS work you can't plug
them in on the first try because they're
4D objects wake up people people trying
to think in 4D can be a humbling
experience and can help you sympathize
with 2D life for example let's imagine a
2d entity is trying to get the sphere
out of this ring for more 3D perspective
the solution is obvious just pull it
forwards but to a 2d entity
disconnecting the two shapes would seem
completely impossible and our solution
would look like magic but we'd have
similar difficulties with 4D objects
these two rings seem like they could
never be separated but they actually
have a gap we can't perceive along the
fourth dimension allowing them to come
apart it drives home the point that to a
fourth dimensional life form we might be
like newborns utterly perplexed by the
most basic of their shapes foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
but shapes are one thing what would it
be like if a fourth dimensional life
form pulled us entirely into their
four-dimensional world the answer might
be the game miyagakare created by the
same developer as 4D toys miyagakare
takes place in a world with four
dimensions though we can only perceive a
3D slice of it but miyagakare allows you
to move your 3D slice along the fourth
dimension revealing new sides to
buildings and Landscapes you couldn't
see before it can be quite trippy to
look at but this ability allows you to
solve puzzles in interesting ways say
there's a wall in front of you you can
move your plane of 3D until you reach a
point in 4D space where the wall isn't
there then walk right through now
despite being in development for a while
the game unfortunately still isn't
available to play for the understandable
reason that trying to build a
four-dimensional world is a 3D
dimensional being is quite challenging
great galaxies where are we
another promising 4D game is 4D minor
created by YouTuber mashpo this game
resembles regular Minecraft at first
until you scroll with the mouse wheel
and realize we're once again seeing a 3D
slice of a much larger 4D landscape
surviving in this world stretches your
mind sometimes you think you're in an
area without trees only to realize
they're all around you just hidden
elsewhere in the fourth dimension other
times you think you found a small cave
only to realize it's huge but most
challenging of all is the fact you
aren't alone in this world those
hovering shapes belong to Fourth
dimensional predators that see you as an
easy meal called hyper spiders their
bodies extend into the fourth dimension
and are considerably larger than we can
fathom because of their fourth
dimensional bodies hyper spiders are
difficult to spot and are even harder to
hide from if you build a house to take
shelter in they'll often appear inside
as if from nowhere this is because his
40 Predators hyper spiders can move
through gaps that us 3D life forms can
easily overlook
meanwhile back on the world in our
Dimension what are we going to do I'm
afraid gentlemen we are at their Mercy
there are other ways of simulating
four-dimensional life forms 4D particle
life is a game that works just like a 2d
particle life simulator except of course
in 4D the artificial life on screen
right now might look like simple
particles but every simulated cell has a
much more complex 4D body it's
interesting to think about how games
have gone from 2D to 3D to now with a
few games 4D although side note many
classic 2D games aren't truly
two-dimensional as characters can pass
in front of and behind objects so their
worlds contain at least some depth
what's really weird is that when you
play a 4D game you're technically
looking at a 3D slice of a 4D World
rendered on a 2d screen so now that no
one is confused let's talk about time
travel
oh
you might have heard that time is the
fourth dimension which raises the
possibility of 40 life but like with
time instead whether or not time is best
classified as a dimension like the
spatial ones has long been a subject of
debate but let's run with the idea after
all you do move through time all of us
right now are constantly traveling
forward from the temporal position we
were in moments ago simply by existing
so by some definitions you're already a
4D life form with three dimensions of
space in one dimension of time what was
that strange field we just passed
through it must have been some sort of
time barrier
the difficulty is of course that we can
only move through time in a single
direction we are constantly traveling
forwards and we cannot go back or even
know where we'll end up if you could see
your fourth dimensional self across time
stretching all the way from your first
moments to your very last it's
interesting to consider how that would
change what it means to be human if from
the very beginning of your story you
knew every moment that's to come would
that even be a life as we understand it
one of the few sci-fi films to seriously
consider the implications of
transcending linear time is a rival the
aliens in this movie called heptopods
seem to experience time in a non-linear
fashion with every moment of their lives
including their death as close to the
present as any other we're not talking
about a life form that can alter time
not yet anyway but rather entities that
can exist at any point along a
predetermined path and as the film
progresses the main human character
begins to perceive time the way the
heptopods do it's an ability that proves
both beneficial and heartbreaking as all
the good and bad in her life become
contemporary instances in time one of
the hardest parts of time passing is
that the future holds many unexpected
tragedies but if you knew every tragic
event in your life before they happened
yet couldn't change anything would that
really make things easier another
reflection on The Melancholy of
non-linear time is the film in
Interstellar particularly in the scene
where the lead character falls into a
higher dimensional space within a
wormhole where they're able to see into
the past and future the strange realm is
called the Tesseract even though it's
not a 4D cube in the traditional spatial
sense but like a rival interstellar's
portrayal of the fourth dimension is
more of a thematic device than a physics
lesson a meditation on times
unchangeable nature we all want to know
where we're going but if you knew where
your ship was headed but couldn't change
course perhaps you'd be better off
keeping your eyes closed
you are now in Dementia by The Fifth
Dimension give me the library of God it
was lost when you pulled me into this
world of yours buddy
[Music]
but what if you could steer the ship
moving across timelines the same way a
higher dimensional life form could move
through space would that make you 5D
life well you ponder that question let's
play some chess and by that I of course
mean 5D chess with Multiverse time
travel 5D chess plays basically the same
as regular chess with the small
exception that if a game just isn't
going your way you can send one of your
pieces backwards through time creating a
new Branch reality where things unfold
differently and you can do this as many
times as you like meaning you have to
avoid Checkmate across multiple
different parallel realities you with me
so far while playing you can take out
pieces from 15 moves ago you can send
your king through time to another
reality erasing your king from the
original timeline and making it
impossible for you to lose in that
Universe there's a strategy called
Jurassic Rook where you send a rook or
Castle all the way back to the beginning
of the game effectively resetting the
timeline to its original state like
you're in Back to the Future it's crazy
and can leave your mind completely
shattered I I just saw a trillion
different realities folding onto each
other like thin sheets of metal forming
single blade yeah yeah the time knife
we've all seen it but what's potentially
even crazier is imagining how fifth
dimensional entities would
hypothetically function in an ecosystem
say you're a 5D organism aware of
yourself across multiple timelines if
you're caught by a predator in one
reality it doesn't matter in another
point in another timeline you're still
doing fine or you could go full Jurassic
rook and take out a past version of that
Predator when they're little or better
yet take out their great grandparent so
that they're never born it's
mind-boggling to think about a whole
speculative ecosystem of 5D species
trying to out Juke each other across
multiple timelines like their Skynet
from the Terminator and to be clear this
vision of The Fifth Dimension is beyond
speculative and hardly the most
scientific but while we're here can we
push things even further
why
this little trinket just sent you into
the sixth Dimension Superman the
dimension behind mirrors you won't get
away with this branching off into
alternate realities from a single
timeline is one thing but what if you
could explore completely new timelines
with completely new rules this
Multiverse model of reality has become a
popular one in recent years with more
and more pieces of media exploring
stories over Divergent timelines Collide
it's a concept that doesn't really line
up with the multi-dimensional theories
of quantum physics but let's not get
into all that this video is already
plenty confusing the most relevant piece
of Multiverse media for our purpose of
visualizing higher dimensional life is
probably the film everything everywhere
all at once it's a story in which
various characters can perceive and even
merge with other versions of themselves
from across alternate timelines an
interesting byproduct of this is that as
humans with brains only meant to pursue
receive a single reality at a time
focusing on one reality often means a
version of the characters and another
reality suffer like a rival and
Interstellar the film's dimension
bending sequences are largely a vehicle
for themes and emotional beats it's not
just a movie about what would happen if
humans had hot dogs for fingers well it
is a movie about that but it's also a
reflection on meaning in the face of
infinity in the context of Limitless
realities what is the worth of a single
moment it's a question that feels
particularly relevant to life in the age
of the internet we can download and
experience all these different
dimensional simulations and it's great
but it can also be overwhelming in one
of the film's most stunning sequences
the main character embodies all possible
versions of herself across every
conceivable reality completely losing
her identity to the void of unlimited
stimulation everything everywhere all at
once is the kind of narrative that can
make you appreciate being here now in
ordinary life form with a reasonable
number of perceivable dimensions
my readings indicate we are not in time
and space as we understand it apparently
the natural laws of our universe don't
operate here
in terms of higher temporal Dimensions
there's no real place to go after you've
encompassed every point in every time in
every possible timeline but if we leave
time and return to spatial Dimensions
we've got room to grow you now know what
a 4D Cube looks like but how about a 5D
cube with an extra dimension of space
instead of time or a 10d cube yes all
these points and lines represent a
single 10-dimensional hypercube
flattened out in a way we can perceive
you can really keep adding additional
spatial Dimensions until things get
exponentially out of control with the
monstrosity that's currently on screen a
16 dimensional hypercube unsurprisingly
there's not a lot of media that tries to
explore life with these types of
Dimensions the closest example probably
comes from Douglas Adams's The
Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy in this
series what we know as mice are revealed
to merely be small protrusions into our
dimension in belonging to vast higher
dimensional beings it's a comedic
concept that riffs on the Trope of rats
and mazes much like how from our
top-down perspective two-dimensional
maze is easy to solve mice in
Hitchhiker's Guide find our mazes
absurdly simple which might hold true
for any higher dimensional being you can
hide nothing from me
my x-ray intelligence we could also head
in the other direction and imagine a
one-dimensional game a concept the same
Creator who made 4D minor has a great
take on the game is technically a
three-dimensional representation of a
one-dimensional field of vision as a
completely 1D game would just be an
impossibly Thin Line playing the
simulation is kind of like living in a
world made solely of barcodes although
with practice you can actually get
better at navigating the strange
environment or how about a Zero
Dimensional game which I guess
mathematically wouldn't be aligned by
but just a single point okay we've
pushed things too far
in the end imagining versions of reality
with a different number of spatial or
temporal Dimensions can be challenging
but there's so many interesting things
you can experience by widening your
perspective some forms of media might
make you wish for extra Dimensions While
others will make you appreciate what you
have it all depends on your point of
view we will not live in a
two-dimensional world we won't go in One
Direction
we will walk through walls we will not
be confined there are plenty of other
games and pieces of media that
experiment with dimensions of space and
time in their own way that I didn't get
the chance to talk about if you found
this subject thought provoking there are
links to all the games and simulations
discussed in this video down below with
more information on all the incredible
people who are building worlds in higher
and lower dimensions
as always thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this entry please lend your
support by liking subscribing and
hitting the notification icon to stay up
to date on all things curious see you in
the next video